how is actor mejía greeting you with his
informative creed for today wednesday
july 14 the positive cases for the
coronavirus continue to increase in the
state now at 10% this percentage has not
been this high since mid
-February the average in cases from day
to day  day is below 450
however the curve of people getting the
vaccine continues to slowly decline
until this morning it is recorded that 46%
of eligible people are
fully vaccinated
under communism this was the message
of many local Cubans for whom
they are on the island
where anti-government protests have
flooded the streets these protests are
the largest against this
government in
decades cubans protest lack of
food and medicine while the
country goes through a crisis of va due  to
the pandemic several people came out to
protest around the world including
here in south las vegas
after a long debate l  concacaf
decided not to sanction mexico and
allow fans inside the stadium for the
game against guatemala
tonight mexico made its gold cup debut
on saturday night where the
cry was heard twice fifa said that
if they manage to identify those involved
they will be ejected from the stadium without
refund and now we move on to
the weather forecast and what to expect
weather wise we will have a hot day
again by today reaching 108 degrees
we could see some drizzle and
lightning by tonight and then by
the end  of the week we will have more
sunny days before the storms return
and the rain have a nice
day I am with mejía and this was your brief
informative for today kirchner spanish
[Music]